[Musica]
con altri colleghi abbiamo scelto di
andare per le scuole di seguire i
ragazzi
perché questa gioventù sono le nostre
colonne quando entriamo nelle nelle
classi cerchiamo di coinvolgere
immediatamente
quindi il primo coinvolgimento è questo
provate a pensare a mettere una città e
una data
provate a pensare anche qui di mettere
una città e una data
allora vediamo che
le guerre su tutte uguali
i profughi sono gli stessi
e ho sempre un dolore le aree di crisi
sono un dolore distruzione
abbiamo già viste in corso abbiamo visto
in afghanistan abbiamo visto di tutto
ucraina adesso
è solo un costo se io vado a vedere i
dati delle nazioni unite
vedo che è l'ucraina hanno già stanziato
per la popolazione 4 miliardi
ma ci sono altre aree di crisi
dove
il costo è minore
e non si raggiungono i livelli
lo scorso anno al 50 per cento è stato
raggiunto 12 milioni di persone
12 milioni di persone che vivono al di
sotto della soglia di povertà
sono numeri che devono far pensare
se noi pensiamo a questo pianeta l'unico
che abbiamo non abbiamo lo di serie b
vediamo che
ci sono 19 conflitti regionali
ci sono 29
instabilità conflittuali
oltre 70 per cento della popolazione
mondiale ne è coinvolta
il 70 per cento
vittime
se devo pensare i numeri dati dalle
nazioni unite
noi vediamo che adesso in questo momento
nazioni unite parlano in ucraina di
circa 3.000 morti tra i civili un morto
e gia un dramma ma se andiamo a pensare
alla siria
350 mila e 200 morti se andiamo a
pensare allo yemen
277 mila morti
numeri che devono far ragionare
numeri che sono importanti
profughi
milioni di persone ci sono bambini di 12
anni che formati in campi profughi
cresciuti in campi profili conoscono
solo la guerra
proviamo a pensare
prima o pensare una scuola elementare e
pensiamo a questi bambini ovviamente più
fortunati ea quelli meno fortunati
allora giro per le scuole con i miei
colleghi che voglio tanto bene
e parliamo di geopolitica aree di crisi
ma più che altro perché vogliamo che i
giovani
capiscano che cos'è questo questo
pianeta sappiano muoversi in questo
pianeta quindi questi sono personaggi
che hanno spiegato alcuni che hanno
spiegato cos'è la geopolitica i testi
sacri del geo politica ma noi italiani
non siamo di meno se andiamo a pensare
una definizione di geopolitica
forse questa è quella più a tagliata e
pensiamo che questo giornale italiana
carlo gen mio ex comandante ha dato una
definizione di geopolitica che da
un'idea di quello che è la geopolitica
che non è
soltanto parte fisico o politico ma è
qualcosa di più che lega i popoli
con le loro tradizioni e cultura se noi
pensiamo quindi una geopolitica legata
da geografia politica e mettiamo insieme
fanno questa geopolitica ma ricordiamoci
che geopolitica e cultura
e io devo dare ai ragazzi
quella parte di coltura che devono
conoscere prima di uscire da una scuola
di affrontare il mondo
geografia la geografia come fenomeni
umani che interagiscono tra di loro
quindi sono qualcosa di più che il fiume
la montagna la città qui parliamo di
etnie e religioni
relazioni sociali
tradizioni
storia perché siamo arrivati a questo
punto
quindi a cultura sottolinea parola
cultura
capire cosa succede
le interrelazioni che ci sono lo stesso
in politica ma non tipo di pulire ma che
cos'è la polizia come senso di
appartenenza comune essere insieme
essere una società con le sue relazioni
interne ed esterne che sono importanti
perché relazionarsi e importante quindi
questo insieme è importante qui
l'appartenenza allo stato
se io
penso a quello che è diritto il nostro
presidente
mattarella
quello che ha detto e da sposare in
pieno la cultura non si ferma neppure di
fronte alla guerra
la cultura unisce supera con fini che
sono dei limiti che essa non contempla
ed è fondamentale per ricreare le
condizioni di pace
presidente sergio mattarella
quindi
in questa in questo ambito anche un suo
mostro nelle mie varie missioni fuori
area
ricordo ero in kosovo stavo rientrando
da patch verso pristina fuori fuori
pesce lungo la strada siamo nel 99 vedo
78 bambini
circa
7 8 10 anni
da una parte e una bambina altra parte e
gli lanciavano i sassi metodo bambini
contro una bambina mio figlio quel tempo
aveva proprio sette anni mi fermo mi
fermi che lo perché che succede
la risposta è stata e serba sì ho capito
ma abbia fatto qualche cosa no e serba
concetto di nemico
sbagliato
se io tra slow questa parola concetto di
nemico a sarajevo qualche anno dopo mi
ritrovo comandante di una divisione
sotto gli ufo rowe e comandante di
un'altra divisione era un colonnello
ungherese
varissimo un fratello
e parlando il più da meno gli ho detto
guarda da tenente io ti stavo aspettando
qui la soglia di gorizia
perché tu è del mio nemico che diceva
francesco io in ungheria aspettavo te
che ed il mio nemico
son passati gli anni
eravamo fratelli d'arma insieme a
sarajevo quindi superiamo il concetto di
parola nemico
lo stesso parola stato è un concetto che
va
esploso e va capito cos'è il concetto
strada in in altre missioni
vediamo
in afghanistan
quello che è successo ero nella zona
rurale verso il pakistan è
nella tradizione nella loro cultura in
in quelle aree al confine con il
pakistan
c'era il pensiero che ho la tradizione
era la loro culto diceva che il
capofamiglia per la persona più
importante la famiglia il primo figlio
maschio i figli maschi
le figlie femmine perché si potevano
vendere gli animali domestici e poi
c'era la voglia la moglie che accudiva
la casa accudiva i campi pro dopo non
poteva toccare nel campo di grano e ne
fare il pane perché era impura dove sta
scritto questo parlando con un campo
famiglia diceva
è la nostra cultura e la nostra
tradizione
me l'ha insegnato al mio padre che gli
ha insegnato mio padre tra manderò mio
figlio concetto errato ma fa capire che
cos'è la cultura di quel di quel posto
area rurale
concetto diverso che era kabul a kabul
dove la donna
invece ha cominciato ad a seguire un
percorso completamente diverso
quello e al ministero degli affari delle
per le donne e questo era l'ospedale per
le donne però hanno cominciato a capire
che esisteva un mondo quindi il concetto
di stato in in afghanistan era
completamente diverso era cambiato
quello che era cavour non era nelle aree
rurali e questo doveva far ragionare
ancora di più
se noi vendiamo pensare al medio oriente
come è nato il medio oriente noi vediamo
che a medio oriente e 1.116 due persone
importanti come sykes picot sono
suddivise le aree in zona di influenza e
hanno costituito delle nuove fatto
nascere nuove
nazioni immaginate questa slide senza il
dei confini delle nazioni quindi
territorio basta siamo sono sangiaccato
anno voto costruire queste nazioni senza
considerare tutto quell'aspetto di
geopolitica che sono le tradizioni le
culture l'etnia le religioni queste in
questi popoli ed è nato questo
medioriente che è instabile
e sarà sempre instabile pensate alla
all'iraq a pensate quello che è la siria
giordania e stabile quello che c'è in
libano il popolo curdo il popolo
palestinese
ecco questo è quello che deve far
pensare è questo che i nostri ragazzi
devono capire perché lavoreranno con col
medio oriente quindi il concetto di
geopolitica è quello di conoscere il
mondo il mondo che è in movimento
muoversi per conoscere per capire e la
cultura è importante
quindi la geopolitiche cos'è
la jolie ha un valore aggiunto
serve per comprendere per capire
per sapersi muovere in questo pianeta
conoscere persone
rispettare le persone perché se noi non
aspettiamo le persone
creiamo degli attriti inutili quindi
bisogna
investire in conoscenza
e incultura cominciano presente
mattarella non nella parola nemico
andiamo oltre
e quindi la cultura e importare il
sapere è se io so riesco a muovermi se
io non so quindi la non conoscenza
porterà a nuovi conflitti ecco noi io
che i miei colleghi giriamo nelle scuole
per questi giovani per cercare di
trasferire il nostro bagaglio culturale
di 40 anni di servizio militare di
missioni all'estero fargli capire che
cos'è questo pianeta andare avanti
cercare di aiutare i giovani che sono le
nostre colonne a superare determinati
concetti e capire che il mondo potrebbe
essere migliore di quello che grazie ai
nostri giovani grazie
[Applauso]